[Music]
this gamer this is a big one I am
thrilled I'm gonna play UFC two with
featherweight UFC champion Conor
McGregor and this is an honor yes oh
yeah well your old friends in here now
now one of your great great great
attributes is your stare down before a
fight you can look into someone's soul
can you give me the pre-fight stare down
to that camera here's mine alright now
the exciting things about this game is
that obviously we get you get to play
yourself and I'm told they've made it
possible for me to play myself yeah I
have not seen it yet but let's check
this out yeah there you are and
please go with me yeah look at that body
I've got that's a weak midsection that's
gay what are you talking about from weak
section to breadbasket I called my foot
is gone straight into the breadbasket
hey how about my eye so I got killer
look at my eye
give me that
coming up next it's a UFC lightweight
division back that's beautiful is that
what it's like
[Applause]
there I am getting moisturizer okay this
is exciting
look at me I have no fear okay here we
go back it away back in a way I'm not
going to let you hear me at first little
angels there
ridiculous I can take much more abuse
than that house we have a very ugly I
could take much more abuse on that I've
been married 14 years look at this oh
you broke my neck now here's the part I
object to what is why are you doing that
when I'm down you bastard maybe I
grapple you in this round that's what
most trying to do and what's the
grappling button l2 and stick for help
from my team Connors like it won't help
this time I'm just gonna move away from
you I move forward now I'm moving away
from you get away from me get away from
me people we're all thinking I hate her
from Waterford my
great-great-grandfather was a bones
matter
wait a minute
why do they stop it that's my technique
like a destroy look at me
that's me after three beers
this is fantastic now I'm just punching
the air is that intimidate anyone to
just punch the air you're just pushing
every button I can think
[Applause]
why was i dragging Kavitha now just
kicking you
no tell you what you look good there oh
my god the money oh look at that I love
that that's how I feel after every show
I almost had it my curat my curiosity is
as a fighter if I came at you let's say
you didn't know me and we're in a bar
okay and I'm I'm saying guy I'm saying
some shite okay I say it some shape
Conor McGregor this called him agree
that and I've had a few too many pints
you wouldn't be if this was the case I
wouldn't even let you this close really
I would have already put you down but I
have the reach this was at me just tell
them what what do you fear about Colonel
Bryan um absolutely nothing jørgen
messin you were drinking okay when I'm
and I'm coming at you with this they
kill your knee yes and then I'm here
then right here it just repeat would you
be wearing slippers when you do right
but then I jump back up again like this
and I come around this way what are you
gonna do all right
you convinced me you would win a fight
I've actually was in a fight once in my
life and I got the [ __ ] kicked out of me
a long time ago and I didn't enjoy that
this I enjoy this was rocky some looks
okay it's UFC two it comes out March 15
this one's a keeper
[Applause]
[Music]
hey if you like this video click here to
watch more you're not looking and it
goes that way can't win